and tristan mckenzie the fastball
curveball combo when he has that working
he is very very tough on opposing
hitters
and a weak ground ball good inning ernie
clement with the charge in the throw and
he got him and the a's go one two three
good start for tristan mckenzie the
indians are coming to bed the big south
paul the manila later sean middle taking
his 22nd turn this season kaiba's pitch
well on the road
tip hung on by murphy and that's a
strikeout up comes ahmed rosario
oh watch this got a chance to beat him
there you go i mean just blew by him
that's his third infield hit he had two
yesterday his first two hits
and when i saw olson go for that ball i
knew mania was not going to get there to
get him because he could just flat out
run man he takes his walk and the
indians have two on with two out with
big harold coming to the plate and the
runners
move
and it's right back up the middle in the
center field ahmed rosario racing around
third he will score defranimal goes to
third big herald delivers and the
indians take a one-nothing lead yeah
there you go that was a good at-bat by
harrell i'll tell you they've been doing
a nice job putting the hits together
recently and now that's what you need
you need a nice two-out base hit early
in the game it'll wake this offense up
and the way they've been swinging
they may keep it going oscar mercado
there he goes and it's a swing and a
miss
so a long inning for sean manaya but the
damage is only one run for the indians
we had to decide
mckenzie a run in the first doing
something he didn't have in his last
start
he's the one that beat us in oakland
yeah the friday night game
he's down on strikes to start inning
number two so here is josh harrison
and that one is smoke to left field
heading over there is ramirez he's going
to play it off the base of the wall
harrison is going to hustle in the
second and he's got a one-out double how
about jay hey high stepping it into
second with a dubsack so runner in
scoring position after the first hit for
the ace here's murphy at 220.
that one is drilled
left center field and nobody's gonna get
that one harrison will score easily
murphy's gonna head into second with a
booming double and this game is tied at
one back-to-back dub sacks holler back
having quality and productive at bats in
situations like this it's it's not
enough to just move jay hey up 90 feet
no no that's not what we're talking
about back to back doubles guys in
scoring position make it hurt we go now
to the bottom of the second inning
bottom third of the indians order coming
up here
there's a fair ball down the right field
line and owen miller
leads off inning number two with a solid
base hit 60 pitches almost with nobody
out
that is one hop anders knocks it down he
flips to second now they're going to
throw to third and it's going to be an
unconventional double play hey at this
point the a's will take it six four five
just how you draw it up kype the old six
four fiver
mile straw is the one indians batter
because of his time with houston astros
who's got good numbers against oakland
rip fair down the third base line into
the left field corner it goes tearing
around second on his way to third ernie
clements to be waved home and he will
score without a throw
look at him completely out of gas after
that long at bat
the frustration of having it end in a
double play
but his hustle off the hit by miles
straw next the indians their second run
of the night
two to one here's amanda rosario
ground ball single into left field
another run will score
three nothing cleveland
and ahmed rosario is two for two tonight
he just keeps on hitting everything in
sight
[Applause]
and the pitch is high and ramirez walks
so the inning continues and i i think it
i think it's also fair to
go back to the weather and that becomes
an issue in innings like this especially
when it's the second inning in a row
where you've really got to work
swinging a miss he came right at him
with a fastball and he strikes out fran
mill reyes to end the inning a couple of
runs for cleveland it's three to one
indians after two seth popped up to the
third baseman his first time up
first pitch to brown
and he drives on right center field and
that baby's gone another long home run
for seth brown his 14th of the year and
now it's three to two oh my goodness he
got all of that one that's what we've
talked about with seth vince that he can
get hot he can really impact the game
that's a fast ball up and seth brown
jumped all over this pitch just the
sound off the barrel kite let you know
fans just watching in oz this baby sails
in tonight fifth inning underway elvis
andrews to lead things off they're good
[ __ ] oh man what a
nice play by mercado
that's a perfect way to play him there
well i think they jumped yeah but you
play him shallow because that's his
stroke and you're taking a base hit away
right here
that's good defense and look at the
frustration
marcano for two
good pitch boy mckenzie he was fired up
pumped that fastball by canna that's
just a second strikeout tonight but
there are two down in the fifth inning
just made him look bad on a really good
slider
back-to-back case for sticks mckenzie
matt olson leading off
look at that and that's a great sequence
man fastball breaking ball breaking ball
see you later three consecutive
strikeouts now for olson since the home
run by seth brown
it's almost like tristan mckenzie
something went off yeah i'll tell you a
great sequence there and he likes that
ball down but he bounced it now jed
lowry oh for two as a pitcher you've got
to understand it
i mean he's rolling that's the combo the
fastball curve he's rolling right now
they're insane starling marty and then
olsson's on deck a's down 3-2 in the
eighth
there's the fastball 94 miles an hour
and marty lines it to right field for a
base hit
here's matt olson
and there's a line drive base hit right
field here comes marty here comes
mercado's throw to the plate they hold
him up he tries to get back to 30 safe
one out and jed lowry one of the best
clutch hitters in baseball steps up
up the middle right to rosario it's
going to get a run home and this game is
going to be tied so jed lowry had to put
it in play and he did
runners at first and third no shift on
for chad
and that one is sliced down the left
field line and it's fair bounces up
against the wall one run scores going to
third is matt olsen he'll stop there and
judd larry has come through again so
here's bradley zimmer who is hitting for
the first time he pinched ran in the
eighth inning oh two pitch swing and a
miss he struck him out and that's the
ball game so zimmer
sees three fastballs swings and misses
at all of them and andrew chaffin what a
job as the runner at second
never
moved